you were to Define what woke means what
what does woke mean to you woke means
living in a delusion and and a reverse
reality of there's no objective truth
that is it's all moral relativism is is
whatever situational ethics what have
you that works towards a certain end uh
and and I think that that's what we see
happening because none of this makes any
sense to stand up there and ask a person
do you identify as black first of all
what does Sam Hill does that mean and
and to to take the type of stance that
she took you know I remember when I was
a kid and I was sitting in the backseat
of the car and I had two aunts on either
side and they were talking to each other
and I interrupted them I got jab slapped
really quick I mean you know it was just
just how it happened with the backhand
and because I understood respect of our
elders we don't have respect of our
elders anymore and that's one of the
things that I saw when I was teaching
High School Deerfield Beach